we did it people
we actually made it to the end of 2020
and what a year it was despite the
plague
the draconian authoritarian perpetual
lockdowns and riots in the streets
i was still able to continue the show
launch my first book do tons of media
appearances and connect with some old
and some new friends it was great to be
on the other side of the interview with
people like tucker carlson
candace owens brian callan ben shapiro
jordan belfort
michael knowles and many others my team
put together a few segments from my
favorite media appearances of 2020.
in a year which really upped the crazy i
hope i added just a little bit of sanity
amidst the madness i wish you guys merry
christmas happy holidays a happy new
year and i look forward to continuing to
make some sense of a world gone mad
see you in 2021 barring a meteor hitting
the earth in the next few days
which probably will happen now take a
look at some of my favorite media
moments
from 2020. your whole life your whole
story
for all for all the good and the tough
times and everything else is a perfect
example of what in a in a strange sense
what america is supposed to be right
you create stuff you don't turn to the
government to do anything
that doesn't mean there wasn't a time
when the government could do some stuff
and was better at doing some stuff the
government at one time did get us to the
moon
but who's getting us to mars it's elon
musk if you're a great scientist
you're right now like you're a great
mind you're a young person you're a
great mind
great scientist do you want a government
job
do you want that's why the worship of
fouchy is a really interesting thing
look he he's a scientist i'm not i'm not
sitting here besmirching the guy
but in effect great scientists go for
other jobs now
there's financial reasons for it there's
freedom reasons for it
you just get trapped in this machine but
really what you're talking about is
do you he's a functionary he's just a
function every if algae right the
government
every month he says something dude don't
wear masks wear masks
don't do anything they do things yeah
it's like at this point though
i think you have to steal okay i get it
buddy
you're in you have to be basking in the
glow of this thing yeah he's loving it
he's just saying [ __ ] he's like almost
like trump he never you ever know what's
going to come out of
his mouth you know what sorry guys just
just do what you're told the [ __ ] that
this guy is elected officials like it's
almost unbelievable
i know you go foul you just keep saying
stupid [ __ ] go ahead you know well it's
like
well because people say you got to
believe the science yeah the scientists
believe the scientists that makes no
sense i mean
you know that science you know science
is not perfection
you know like science the basis of
science is not to believe sciences try
to
challenge every hypothesis and improve
on the way you see if something is true
or false is by testing it and
challenging it and it evolves over time
all the things that i was i was a
scientist by all major biochem in
college i have a degree
and most of the stuff i was taught is
not true like i had false beliefs like
my whole thoughts i'm like well you know
the brain can't grow new cells
i was taught that and yeah that's not
true and and that's the that's the
purpose of science right like you see a
theory and you try
to you either prove it or you disprove
it or whatever else but we've we put
these phrases
you know believe in science the same
people that say believe in science will
also tell you that you're allowed to
select your gender
right so it's like i you know i'm not a
scientist but i'm pretty sure having a
penis makes you male and having a vagina
makes you female that your preference of
sex is a different issue
you can prefer whatever the hell you
want to prefer by the way you could also
transition but that doesn't change your
biology and saying that doesn't make you
anti-trans
if someone's trans right if someone is
born
biologically male and then transitions
to become
female effectively they're not
biologically a female that's just the
truth
question so this is like i think we it's
interesting we agree on on so many
different things in a sense like
long obviously long island creates a
certain sense of reality
it's almost like a practical way of
thinking yeah that i buy into where like
for instance i know
like do you think it's fair that girls
that transition are winning all the
medals now in women's sports like what
do you think
you mean boys that transition to females
that then are beating the crap out of
all these no of course it's not but now
you've got the feminists saying that
that's
okay but it's not but like it's
obviously just
not yeah it's just not nothing against
the girls i'm not i'm not saying
you should have a separate leap for all
the trans people that won't compete
against each other because
it's just you know by the way i'd be
okay with that if they want that
you know whatever it's because it's just
a different musculature it's obvious
it's just you know what's it seems like
it seems that like
again i always say it's on both sides
but right now it's whoever really is out
in full force it's like
they ignore the obvious like they say
things that go against the obviousness
of life and general common sense
and they try to justify it by shouting
you down with labels
and identity politics and if you don't
agree with them
you're evil you're this you're that
you're evil you know dave you and i are
a lot alike i might be slightly better
looking but we share
same common interests and i look at i
don't know if i'm overreacting
with this chaos but i think you and i
both
recently joined a special club wasn't
the mile high club but it was a special
club
care to uh explain
greg i suspect you're not talking about
the club that owned this book the plus
which is one of the best reads of the
year
i think you're talking about another
club which is which is the gun owners
club and yeah we both did and look
i've only lived in new york and now i
live in los angeles i've only lived
in these two crazy places but after
watching what has gone on
for the last two months in america you'd
actually have to be bananas to not at
least
strongly consider taking your protection
of your family and your property
into your own hands i mean we're
watching mobs
not only burn down stores and break
windows and attack people on the streets
but literally stop cars in the middle of
the street you saw what happened to the
mccloskey family who had to defend their
property
uh in missouri there's all sorts of
stuff here that you know
as american citizens we have the god
given right that is
enshrined in the bill of rights which is
still a pretty great document
uh the second amendment which is the
right to bear arms and protect yourself
and uh you and i are doing what you're
supposed to do as an american if they're
gonna defund the police
well then i'm gonna defend myself so
never have i had less faith in the media
to bring us
any element of truth on on this sort of
stuff but where do you come down on on
you know you have a whole chapter in
here about how to spot fake news what
does your media diet consist of these
days
i mean i assume you still read the new
york times even though it's labeled both
of us gateways to the
to the nazi party yes yes
it's a seminal moment in my life when my
dad went to get a bagel and coffee
at the same place he does every sunday
for the last 40 years and someone had to
bring the new york times up to him and
say oh i didn't know david was the
leader of the alt-right
was a really wonderful moment well i'll
tell you this just in the last couple
days
uh the new york times did a story on
misinformation in the age of coronavirus
and they talked about a tweet that went
viral and a bunch of a bunch of people
we know stephen crowder and
brit hume and a few other people tweeted
this article the article was eventually
taken down by medium not by the author
who was analyzing data
it was taken down by medium and they
talk about how this is
this is misinformation because he he
wasn't being alarmist about coronavirus
i happen to know the author it's a guy
by the name of aaron jin i think he's a
decent fella
i retweeted the article because i
thought you know in a time when it's
almost impossible to know who's telling
the truth i think it's important that we
all hear different
perspectives on things so they include
me in this chart showing that when i
tweeted it it really started going viral
and it's all about misinformation so i
screenshot it and i put it up and then i
didn't even tag the author from the new
york times because i don't even bother
tagging these people anymore because
as you know they're not journalists
they're quote-unquote journalists
i didn't even tag the guy but he wrote
back and said something like we didn't
quote
mention you you were just in a graph
but i'm glad you think you're flattered
and i thought you know it's it's it's
this exact
type of glib double speak that
is exactly this is what i said to him on
twitter i mean that you guys are
destroying your own profession
you're telling me when you put my name
in a chart in an article about
misinformation
that's not mentioning me it's not
mentioning me
and of course if you google the
definition of the word mention it it
qualifies as a mention
but but what's happening right now is
all i've all i ask i tweet this all the
time
all the media has to do you want to shut
up ben shapiro you want to stop
scary dave rubin you know what you do
you start behaving honestly
but they can't do it they have the ship
has sailed
the thing that is the new york times is
just the shell of the new york times
with a bunch of progressive activists uh
underneath it i know someone that you
know too
that works at the new york times who uh
although i don't think this person's
talking to me anymore
would oft tell me about how horrifically
woke
the uh entire newsroom had become and
that there's nothing even remotely close
to true
coming out of that place they don't even
have an uh ombudsman ombudsman is that
the word
yep yeah they don't even yeah they don't
even have an ombudsman anymore which is
the person who's supposed to be
fact checking the fact checkers in
effect uh you know a public editor they
don't even have that anymore
it is propaganda cnn is propaganda i'll
give you i'll give you a real good
example of this in in december
i i missed you by a day but we both
spoke at the turning point student
action summit event in west palm beach
and the day that i spoke i spoke that
morning trump spoke that afternoon and i
had never heard trump speak
in real time before in real life and
we're watching the speech and i i was
actually in the second row
and he you know it's trump he goes up
there he's half stand-up comic he's
you know he's you know he's getting the
crowd going the whole thing and then he
says this thing about and he gives an
hour and a half speech and it's half
prompter half off the cuff
and he says this thing about wind power
and he goes you know i love wind power
nobody knows more about wind power than
me i've studied wind power my whole life
and then he goes on and on about wind
power back to the script but that line
obviously those few lines were obviously
improved and i turned to david and i
said i bet you
that within an hour there's going to be
an article about how trump says he knows
more about
wind power than anybody and he's studied
it his whole life
and then voila all the articles come out
donald trump says he knows more about
wind power
than anyone and it's like man you idiots
he was
joking and then actually made some
interesting points about the validity of
wind power and how important
it should be or should not be um and
then link that also to failed other
green projects that we've done like
solyndra and a whole bunch of other
stuff
anyway so where do i get my diet from
it's very difficult i think you guys at
the daily wire are doing a nice job i
think the blaze is doing a nice job i do
occasionally read some things
out of the times in the washington post
but they're pretty crappy i try to pay
attention
you know what i basically try to do is i
on twitter i follow a multitude of
people from different perspectives
and i try to just whittle that into
something that's true
um but i think one of the saving graces
for me
um which is why i don't envy the guys
that have to do the grind every day the
hours and hours of content every day
is that it's really hard it's hard to
it's hard to distill truth out of this
madness all the time
and uh i think you do a pretty damn good
job of it but it is not easy to do
it's not a fun word it's not it's
conservative right so both are the right
oh
liberal sounds funny does liberals sound
funny anymore all the words have become
so
tainted now that like but that's but
that was really
why i wrote the book because it was the
ideas think for yourself
you don't if there if there are ten
important issues there's obviously more
than that but if there are ten important
issues
if you and i agree on six of them and
two of them we're kind of still figuring
out and two of them we absolutely
disagree on well candace i still want to
live in the same country as you
i still want to be your friend and
that's the thing that everyone is just
getting rid of right and and i am so
happy you talked about that because
i i totally agree with you that the
puritan conservatism doesn't work
and i think that i've actually tried to
get rid of that and i i've dealt with it
a lot i mean you saw me literally
i feel like i've grown up politically in
front of everybody um and i dealt with
that more maybe even more than me
because when i started
i was starting from like a political
base right like i was on the left
i was on the young turks i was a
progressive and then i started waking up
but my base was kind of political i was
a political science major i always cared
about this
that first time you walked into my
studio as you uh said before like you
were kind of
totally figuring it out i was open and i
was open to listening and and
i never wanted to be the person that
pretended to be someone that i wasn't if
i wasn't comfortable answering a
question i would say you know this is my
feeling on it but i don't really know
much about it so that's it
yeah and it was great and honestly i
always tell people that was such a good
moment for me to be on your show because
you were so accepting of that you were
like you don't need to commit to this or
this and have an answer right now
and i actually ironically had the
opposite experience when i went on joe
rogan where i was like i don't i feel
like
there's something more like i don't
trust the climate change and he's like
you need to pick or be agnostic and
and i was like i just my feeling is that
it's not right because i was told i was
gonna die when i was in high school
uh because of climate change and i'm
still here but i haven't researched it
that's because you're a servant right
but i haven't researched it and i felt
like
he wanted me to pick one camp or the
other and so what i try to do even in
being a conservative
is be more open and especially on the
pro-choice stuff because i say to people
my friends have gotten abortions people
that i've grown up with have gotten
abortions
and i know if they didn't go to the
abortion clinic saying i want to kill a
baby in fact i know what they learned
in school that it was the compass else
yeah right so how can you then
we we have to be warmer right in saying
and how about saying you know what
if you got even if you got an abortion
you can still be pro-life
and that is the stance that i take
because it's it's less black and white
it's less like
you killed a baby you're a murderer that
doesn't work that's the same kind of
stuff the left does on the other side
if i believe in my position and i do
that it's a life
how about saying them i know that you
can it can be very confusing when you're
young
and you're told that your whole life's
gonna get ruined if you get pregnant
it's just a clump of cells and you can
make a decision but you
you can change your mind there's so much
there so so first off partly why
the left is always screaming is they
don't know really
what their starting point is so so
people on the right
generally if you're if you're an
american you believe in individual
rights you believe that every single
person regardless of their skin color or
sexuality or gender blah blah should
have the same exact rights
on the left you sort of have this idea
that the state is kind of supposed to do
a lot of stuff
and then the disagreement is how much it
should do so the best way i could
explain this is
if you think back the 2016 election it
was like if you pictured
you know marco and cruz and trump all up
there
they didn't have massive substantive
issues they had issues about personality
right so trump was you're little marco
and you're lying ted and you're
this one and but they didn't but they
sort of all believe in the constitution
they all believe that america is
fundamentally good in the rest of it
if you look at where the democrats have
been for the last couple years
it's like they kind of don't really
believe in the constitution all the time
they
kind of tell you that they never say
words like freedom and liberty imagine
if someone walked on stage
at one of those things and said the word
freedom people would be like you're at
the wrong event buddy
like what are you talking about here um
but
i think that gets to why they're so
hysterical all the time because
they have this idea that the state is
supposed to do a lot and then the next
guy is like no the state should do more
and then you're kind of like oh maybe it
should otherwise i'm a bad guy so it's
like
when they say they're for 15 minimum
wage and then rashida talib comes along
that's you know bernie's been pushing 15
forever
which is a horrible idea on so many
levels and and antithetical to american
ideas because why should the government
be able to force a private company what
to do and
put that aside but then rashida comes
along and she's like no it should be 20.
and it's like well she's kind of right
because you just made up a number so
let's why not make up another number and
then then somebody's going to come along
and go regina you're a racist it's 25.
you know so it's like so they don't know
what their fundamental principle is and
because of that
because of that that's why they're crazy
all the time because constantly you're
looking around going
who's going to outdo me on something and
i think that's a fundamental
piece of why having a debate about
abortion
which i've tried to do a million times
lila rose who you pat her on on this
show right
so she's been on my show i think she's
wonderful obviously we have some
disagreements on this stuff
i have put out there many times on
twitter i would love to have a
pro-choice advocate come on the show
with lila rose we've invited alyssa
milano and
the collection of usual suspects totally
respectfully we've reached out publicly
and privately
nobody nobody and there's a reason for
it it's not just that dave rubin is
mean or something like that or that
lilo's a liar
or something like that these not true
statements obviously it's that they
don't want to actually
debate these things in a calm way
because they need the emotion
to override the argument so how do you
beat the mob well the mob
actually preys on the fact that people
are afraid
and i think there's a lot of people that
think oh if i could just be i can sit
this one out let me just sit this one
out let me be quiet this time it'll pass
it'll pass it doesn't pass that's the
thing they have preyed on the fact that
good people
are good people and they have used that
against us
and it's it's the frog in the boiling
pot if you
think that your acquiescence or that
your silence is saving you
you're actually turning the dial up on
the pot that you are in
and as you know it does not end well for
the frog right like that frog is fried
at the end of that thing
and i think that that is what has
happened here and that that in many ways
is why i wanted to write the book more
than anything else because that was the
idea it was like
i don't think that everything i present
here is the most legendary political
idea of all
time but i think i've been able to
communicate ideas in a good way
and and i've paid the price for that um
and there are rewards absolutely based
on the price you paid too
and i don't say paid the price to get
any pity points i don't want any pity
points
i've gotten the rewards of that too
right like it's it's awesome it's
cool i wake up and i'm ready to go every
day you know how do you feel like we can
emotionally
arm ourselves for taking on backlash
because if we want to be great in our
lives at any stage any
any uh decade of our life there's going
to be critics haters
backlash mob whether it's online offline
whatever
what do you think we can do emotionally
to prepare for that besides
what i think is the best thing is just
to do it as often as
often as possible to be able to stomach
it and say okay i'm still alive i'm
still here
yeah like it didn't kill me it hurts
yeah but i'm stronger
well partly it's that partly it's that
partly it's basketball it's been a theme
here so like partly it's why did michael
jordan practice harder than anybody else
right like that is the known thing
kobe was like it too it's like why did
they do it barkley didn't love practice
now
allen iverson famously practiced that
you know exactly and that's not to say
they weren't great players
but alan iverson and charles barkley
never won championships and
michael jordan won six championships and
he was in the final six times right and
he
systematically eliminated every one of
his peers to get there
um so partly it's just that you gotta
you know douglas murray who i've had on
my show who's a brilliant conservative
political thinker from the uk and one of
the greatest writers that i think we
have in modern times
um he said to me once he said you know
if you get
in the pool he said in a british accent
if you dip your toe in the pool you
might find out that the water is not
that cold
and i actually think that that's the
right idea we you know
there's nothing to fear but fear itself
it's something like that that we create
these monsters
and then when you actually go ahead and
and do whatever you're supposed to do
you might
step in the pool and be like damn i
thought the water was gonna be freezing
but it turns out it's 92.
it's fresh yeah and that's not to say
it's going to be perfect because trust
me it won't be you will lose friends i
mean
we've all been through versions of this
people that you love will suddenly say
the worst things about you you'll watch
i'm seeing some of this now
i'm getting a lot of um support from
my sort of right-leaning friends so you
know shapiro and peterson and glenn beck
and dennis prager that crew
a lot of my my lefty guys who have been
with me all along the road have
completely abandoned me
because they don't want to just deal
with any of the backlash and i also
think this is a whole other topic
but i think that goes to a little bit of
the lefty mind which is in constant
protection mode
um that's that's like sort of like a
whole separate thing but
you got to get in get in the game
because the game is coming for you
anyway whether you like
you can say i'm not playing but it's
what we talked about with politics
before the game is being played man
you're
that's like saying you know if we were
looking at a chess board it's like you
are one of the pieces whether you like
it or not and if the whole board
is being shifted around well you got to
move with it
they they will they will have a
journalist on and he'll say
the equivalent of of uh two towers
nine nine eleven yeah all the people
have died horrible equivalent of that
is dying every single day and people
still don't get it and it's like
is that what you're saying and are you
do you mind like
having some caveats around that how old
are they
are we sure of that are they all being
tested they're all these questions
where you're like you're you're just you
are it's almost like they
want this lockdown to go on forever they
do well first off their ratings are up
in the midst of this because we're all
trapped at home so let's not the media
is dead i mean that that's an important
thing to just like we have to just say
it and know it
the mainstream media is just absolute
dead cnn is the wwe
it is i mean i think that moment when
you saw that moment when chris cuomo
walked out of his basement
yeah and they said well he's been he's
been in quarantine for three weeks and
here he come and he had the shivers and
he chipped a tooth because he had
coveted
and it's like he comes up and he's
sweating and then he announces oh it's
because he was working out downstairs
while he had covered the whole thing's
it's all fixed i mean just a week before
he had said he was in
quarantine for three weeks it turns out
a week before he got into a fight with a
biker outside of his house in the
hamptons and there's video it's like
it's
all made up nonsense we are watching wwe
skits in front of us and pretending it's
real
well why don't people get in no they so
i'm on a book tour right now i have done
every freaking podcast you can think of
i've been on every fox show repeatedly
i would go on every single cnn show here
i'm saying it again i have not gotten
one invite not one invite from msnbc
they're just afraid they just they just
my only caveat though would be i would i
would only do it live because i don't
trust them on the editors side but
fox i go on live they don't tell me to
say anything i was supposed to be on
uh perino right before i got here but
then this flynn story dropped so they
canceled me like they're
so polarized aren't we in this country
this that i mean it's just so [ __ ]
well i think most of us are like this
most people i think we're the fortunate
ones don't you no i think we're
fortunate
we're fortunate in that we're not like
completely partisan
crazy people wandering around thinking
that nazis are hunting us down
or that half the country is evil or
something like that most people aren't
there's really a lot of ways to win this
presidential election for democrats and
it's not just getting all those
crusty white guys in diners in um you
know the midwest
nothing against guys and diners in the
midwest
i swear the trump campaign is paying
that woman she's just she's just an ad
for trump
dave rubin joins the house the reuben
report on youtube our old friend joins
us here on set
dave great to see you tonight it's good
to see you before you say anything
tucker i just want to be very clear the
woman you're talking about right there
yeah cliff that's jennifer rubin i am in
no way related i
actually forgot the same very important
that i say this at the beginning
clearly she's a plan what kind of
conservation she and the jeb bush's
former spokeswoman who's on msnbc you
watch somebody like you know what
i'm voting for trump i don't care it's
really confusing it's unbelievable
anyway let me ask you
how dehumanizing do you think it is to
see people in the media who appear
intent on dividing the country along
racial lines
to dismiss people on the base of their
skin color like how do we get to this
place
who was that guy that wanted his
children not to be judged by the color
of their skin
monuments the content of their character
that guy
was kind of right that guy mlk junior
obviously
he was a liberal he was a liberal but
the progressives have nothing to do
with true liberalism and there's a
hilarity going on here because
for years they've been screaming that
all of us anyone who's not awoke
intersectional progressive is a racist
but what was going to be at the end of
the road of that at the end of the road
is exactly what's happening right now
they would have to turn it on themselves
and now they are turning it on
themselves so msnbc is now putting up
people to basically say
forget those republicans and
conservatives and trump supporters that
are racists
we're the racist because in an hour from
right now there's going to be a
democratic debate i think it's on cnn
and
guess what's going to happen it's going
to be all white people thank god
elizabeth is one 1000
24 it's a native american or whatever it
is i don't know what happened andre yang
he should be in there but his asian-ness
doesn't even count right because asian
doesn't sort of fit into the
intersectional
calculator so this is this is the end
game of what all of these competing
what they're really doing is as i think
you're suggesting if you want to be
precise about it they're blaming black
voters
i mean there's a reason the only thing
blacks aren't supporting their own i
mean think how insane
they're turning to the african-american
electorate the democratic party and
saying you're bigots
yeah like the rich people on msnbc
people like i can't remember her name
but the woman
you shared in the last name that's what
they're doing jennifer rubin
that's what they're doing yeah well you
may remember that at the state of the
union last year when president trump
said we have the lowest all-time black
unemployment
and the cameras flashed to the
congressional black caucus and they sat
there like this
now if you cared about your country if
you cared about black people or just
citizens of your country wouldn't you
be happy that they have low unemployment
that would be good
but if you're a partisan hack then you
wouldn't care about that and i think
most people are waking up to this stuff
i mean it's
i i sent out a tweet at the beginning on
on january 1st
saying this is the year of the implosion
of this thing
of wokeness it has to implode now
because elizabeth has to call bernie
a misogynist and someone else has to
call bernie a racist
because that's all they got because they
can't they can't debate on policy they
can't really debate
on taxes or foreign policy or any of
these things so they have to get you
on all of these things because it's sort
of worked in a lot of ways
against conservatives right you're one
of the few guys that consistently stands
up against it
but it silences a lot of people and i
think this is i think this is the year
that it
it just they've cried wolf the polling i
look at suggests that really nobody is
for this crap
other than a very tiny percentage of
msnbc hosts for example but like your
average person of all
any color doesn't like this garbage
nobody cares it's it's an athama and
it's a reverse of what the american
dream is
nobody cares what your skin color is
nobody cares
what your gender is or even your
sexuality or any of these things
if you're an american and you live by
the laws of america
and you work hard and and try to better
your life and your family's life
that's what this whole thing is about
but why do they never talk about that
why why do they why are they afraid to
say words like liberty and freedom
imagine that
imagine those you know who said those
words tulsi gabbard said it and now
she's out
they hate her right yeah conservatives
we tend to see people as individuals
we don't see them as black or white or
are gay
or presbyterian or jewish we tend to see
them as individuals
and i think that's a fundamental
difference would that be
an assessment you would also agree to
well yeah well it's it's the fundamental
difference between say leftism
and conservatism but it also is the most
fundamental building block that you can
have not only for
a country i mean we have this in america
this beautiful
uh document called the constitution that
lays out our rights and then the bill of
rights which expands those rights
um but the government did not give us
our rights right these are god-given
rights these rights the government can
take away your rights but it can't give
them to you
but once you say the group is above the
individual
you have to throw out the individual who
dare
thinks freely who dare takes another
position so a very simple way i could
explain this to you
is so on a on an issue like abortion um
you know you see something right now
where the left which used to basically
say
you know we're for abortion but you
can't have abortions eight months in you
know they had
some guard rails against it now of
course uh governor you as a as a
conservative now you're completely
against that and that's just fine
but the left used to have some semblance
of a mechanism to be able to fight its
most
radical elements they no longer do so
everyone
on stage right now at these debates and
biden might be the slight exception
slight exception i'm not even sure but
these people they won't put a
an end point on abortion i mean everyone
in their right mind of course knows that
at seven months
this is this is a child uh this is a
living being
so this is the problem that once you
start viewing people as
as the collective you're unable to
uh understand that they might have
differences with you because you've
defined them already
and what i would rather do and i think
conservatives have been very good at
this in the last couple years
is say i don't care what your sexuality
is i don't care what your gender is or
your skin color or the rest of it do you
have good ideas
and can we work together to hopefully
create a society
that's truly tolerant for as many people
as possible
and that's why i consistently find
myself building bridges in places that i
i didn't think would have existed a
couple years ago right now the idea of
socialism
is suddenly popping up in america which
is the
genuinely the worst set of collectivist
ideas that you could possibly ever have
that hundreds of millions of people have
died in history
under and it's popping up because if you
listen to what's happening
on the left right now politically
because they've outsourced god imagine
if one of those people on stage
said that they were a real believer
imagine if any of them maybe biden could
do it
but but but really the rest of them
can't they would never really say that
they're a believer now i don't know what
they are and i wouldn't want them to say
anything that's not true
to themselves um but they would be
mocked by
by everything mainstream everything
mainstream would mock them
the way that everything mainstream mocks
any
christian that happens because they're
usually on the right they happen to be
conservatives
but look what they're offering us now
their answer
is okay we've removed god from the
equation and what do we get we get
government
and they they now pray basically to
government they think that they
can figure out somehow by sitting in a
room with a bunch of other politicians
and bureaucrats the worst
sort of people that exist they
i didn't even mean that to be funny but
actually
i mean but that's what they think they
think that they can
rejigger all of humanity in a way that
will be
so much better than everything that came
before them
and not only can't they they are going
to do the complete
reverse so that
if for no other reason if for no grand
revelation or something like that
that would be a reason to be respectful
of people that are believers
because they can fight that in a way
that secularists can't the good liberals
don't have enough juice in and of in and
of themselves they don't have enough
juice to fight that that's why
liberalism has collapsed
in the name of progressivism and if you
watch the debate last night you may have
heard a lot of this
program we would like to bring mr steyer
in on this conversation
if you think that was distracting you
are not alone cbs moderators have been
criticized for
quite a messy debate joining me now dave
rubin host of the reuben report and
author of the upcoming book
don't burn this book and we certainly
won't we'll have you back to talk about
that
um you know fox news when when we host
debates we use a little bell or a little
buzzer
that makes it very clear when somebody's
time is up
they didn't have any of that last night
yeah well dana it's always good to be
with you you know that little skirmish
you just played there
that little five seconds i mean that was
basically the most sensible part of the
entire debate
i mean the whole thing is so confusing
right now
because the democratic party is
splitting into at least
two parts right now perhaps more but at
least two uh you know you've got sort of
the
the socialist progressive lefty far
left wing which is the bernie elizabeth
warren wing and then you have the at
least
slightly more moderate somewhat still
liberal more blue dog democrat
um bernie sorry uh mike bloomberg
and biden part of it but watching them
fray and watching
this thing go out of control it's like
these people should not be on stage
together
they should be separate parties at this
point and that's why the the fighting
over each other and the stammering and
the and the talking over
each other it's like yeah you guys don't
have a cohesive set of ideas that bring
you together as a party
so of course this is what we're gonna
get and as for the the moderators it's
like yeah you need
you need to tell these people to be
quiet and make sure they control
themselves otherwise you end up getting
joe biden yelling at everybody which
that seems
and the candidates they're fighting for
all the marbles right now because it is
crunch time
last night i was watching your twitter
everybody should follow you on twitter
one of the things that you talked about
was that there was something missing
sorry about that no i like the twitter
um i want to show you this clip from uh
last night this is tom steyer talking
about
government and then i want you to tell
people what you thought was missing from
debate the debate last night watch
i don't believe that a government
takeover of large parts of the economy
makes any sense for working people or
for families
i think that what we need to do is to
present an alternative that includes
a vibrant competitive private sector
but we all know unchecked capitalism has
failed
the answer is no not for the government
to take over the private sector though
the answer is for us to break the
corporate stranglehold on our government
and have the government work for the
people again dave what'd you think of
that
well there's nothing like a billionaire
telling me that unchecked capitalism has
failed somehow he managed to do okay in
it
um but but forget about steyer because
you know his appearances
most people are sort of pointless i mean
look yeah you've got you've got the
socialist bernie and the true capitalist
bloomberg
at each other that's that's the future
of this fight
but there's a couple things going on
here i mean when when steyer and and the
rest of them
when when they talk about whatever use
the democrats believe
capitalism still has the base doesn't
care about that they
are socialists and whether you want to
call it socialist
or communist or democratic socialist
whatever phrase you want to use that's
fine
but that really is what the base is so
when bloomberg talks about building a
business successfully when bloomberg by
the way
he actually wore an american flag pin
which i didn't even notice until
afterwards someone pointed out because
the entire thing
nobody says anything positive about
america they you know words like freedom
imagine if someone said the word freedom
or
liberty or anything positive about this
incredible country you have
what they do is they constantly tell you
how good other countries are
so apparently sweden and denmark it's
usually sweden but bernie was big on
denmark last night
these tiny scandinavian countries with
mostly
homogeneous populations although now
that in the last five years they've had
immigration they have all sorts of other
problems
but they use that as a model where we in
america we've got 350
million semi people from every walk of
life we've given more freedom to
everybody
and somehow they can't even seem to
choke out anything
positive about america and then in the
few moments where
biden who's a little more old-school
he'll say something about the
constitution
and you can almost feel it in the room
that it's like constitutional
what does that have to do with what
we're talking about i'm in complete
agreement with you about the pants thing
uh and as you can see here in los
angeles uh we have been reduced to
wearing bathing suits it doesn't matter
that's the point people we're all
americans
it doesn't matter if you're wearing a
bathing suit or jeans
it just doesn't matter but greg yes you
are right you are right when things
actually hit the fan when when it's
suddenly when you suddenly have real
issues to deal with
nobody cares about race nobody cares
about sexuality or gender or any of it
that was one of the best intros i've
ever heard you give because we're all
americans right now we've got a real
problem to face
and when you have real problems the
imaginary problems
of the progressives really disappear
into nothing
yeah i'm just grateful that you were
wearing something
a blast from the past i say that only
because he was with us in 2016 for our
election coverage
when we were blasted so that's that's
how i came up with that little phrase
it's our pal dave reuben thank you what
happened i thought that clavin just got
like more hair younger and gayer
a little gay yeah yeah hold on i want to
be pull on that let's just
go through a couple things here guys
first off you've left me here with
clavin's old glass
can i have your glass because i sense
you're not going to be doing anything
much much no imbibing let's start with
that that's number one but before i do
that
i did bring my special thick rim
election glasses because you know a lot
yes because you know a lot of times on
msnbc
you know they're wearing glasses now
these are not real glasses these are
prop glasses i actually have 20 20
vision
but to make a point when you're a
newscaster and as you guys are blowing
up and leaving me here in los angeles
and
going to nashville it's very exciting
knowles i'm really pissed at you um
you know i you guys are going to have to
do more of this you're going to have to
get thick grim
black that's that's not quite worthy and
then when you make a point then and
you're always making points and then you
keith wow that's good i did that and
and then you can also do this oh my god
i wish you'd make a point
because i'm all in i don't know if
you're allowed to i'm 100 reporting
biden is the president you see you see
how i did that my problem with that i
always get mistaken for maddow every
time i wear those glasses
and it's too much i don't know how to in
tennessee that's not gonna work well in
la it worked very well but
tennessee i can't do it so much of what
we hear about from the left
is exactly what 1984 is about so words
are violence now but violence is not
violence these are things
that they create to actually make us
question everything and then once you
question
everything well then gender is up for
question
and all of the things that should be
settled are no longer settled
and then what i completely forgot about
that i found was interesting is that one
of the things that they're also trying
to sort of
untie that the ministry of truth is
trying to untie
is the idea of time and it does feel
like right now that
time feels a little weird it's partly
because of lockdown
partly because you know we're trapped at
home we're all on social media
but doesn't time feel sort of sort of
strange right now like anything could
happen at any given minute
right and i think that all leads to a
sort of
well sick society where two plus two
eventually
will be five if they just tell you there
are so many of these
contradictions or absurdities that come
up i mean the three
slogans of the party that you've always
got to repeat they've got it on the back
of the book right here
war is peace freedom is slavery
ignorance is strength this could be the
chance
of protesters that we see marching all
around the west quite literally i mean
one of the things that i talk about all
the time now is that it's the
anti-racists
who are the racists right if you if all
the people that are running around now
proclaiming that the rest of us are
racists they're the ones that are
pushing racism into society every
everywhere they're the ones that are
saying black people should have special
dorms
and that white people shouldn't you know
be uh be allowed to have certain jobs or
that they shouldn't be considered
equally
those are racist notions so we live in a
time where
everything has been flipped and for the
few of us
that have a little bit of the spark of
winston it's like how do you make sure
you're not one of the people who at the
end is going two plus two equals five
i'm not sure i i'll tell you one other
thing i'm actually watching the
handmaiden's tale
right now did you watch it i did i've
seen some of it so so i'm watching it
right now
the parallels to 1984 are absolutely
incredible because this is exactly
uh what the main character june is going
through and
it's so funny because the show came out
a couple of years ago and everyone kept
saying this is what's happening in
trump's america
except i'm watching it now in the midst
of you know what's happening with black
lives matter and everything else and
it's like no it's all
the left it's this america this is
america it's not trump that's doing this
it's the other guys that are doing this
so i think more than anything else
there's a beautiful thing when you read
a work of fiction when you can go holy
cow this was not only it must have been
true or true enough to have made sense
when it was written what year was the
book written like i guess written in
1948 published i think in 1949. okay so
49 i mean think about that 70 plus years
ago
but yet feels like literally everything
we're going through
right now yeah that's an incredible uh
compliment to a writer and to a to a
work
and he articulates this concept i mean i
think the great one you use
is that the people who say they're
anti-racist are the ones
who are acting in a racist way and the
way george orwell describes it is he
calls it
doublethink so doublethink
is this idea that you you hold
two contradictory ideas at exactly the
same time
so you can never admit that the ideas
don't make any sense but you so for
instance
we have to get rid of america's terrible
past
which had segregation and the way we're
going to do that is institute
segregation through segregation look
think about it this way what's like the
hottest book
on the left right now it's white
fragility yes what's the subtitle of
white fragility i don't know what it is
exactly but in essence it's
something like how white people can blah
blah that's racist
yeah that in and of itself is racist
forget white fragility
well but then if you say how white
people the implication is all white
people are
this whatever this is that is racist so
you they hold these
two ideas that are completely at odds
with each other
and they hold it because that allows you
to believe
anything basically at any given time if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell